time to play chess chess time tank ready
good luck oh strong player oh thanks so
much
uh what to play play london
man it's it's been over a day since i
last played
a game of chess trying to remember how
the pieces move
pretty sure this is a strong move
uh let's take bishop c4 enjoying the
position
have the quintessential development open
file oh the bishop's not hanging but i
can take it
the pawn is still weak try and take the
knight and then take the pawn
and then maybe lose a pawn but maybe win
a pawn
yeah i think i'm waiting back upon
there's no queen f6
oh that's a tricky move
um that's a confusing move too
let's take it and trade everything
what's going on
oh i have to defend c2
okay i'm down a lot of time too
da okay let's go for activity
i'm in a little bit of trouble here
also thanks for the hype people
oh materials equal actually
i meant to play rook c2
okay got a pass pawn
try and work my way up the board
[Music]
this is just a draw but it could get
interesting
a dirty flag
it's helpful having a queen that can
check from a distance
man i feel like i was down on time hi
oh hi i wanted to start eating healthier
so i decided whenever i crave fast food
i
will simply donate to eric to prevent my
accountability so
wait so that means it's better if you
don't donate or do donate
oh forgetting me re-addicted to chess
area
so many so many things with addiction
okay
uh let's hurry and
uh thanks for that who is that that's
someone
arjun singh and
kasp cast hypernova
yeah whatever whatever system works to
make you a better person
i'm already in some trouble
okay let's dirty flag bits
i might just be meeting here wow this is
completely winning
but white has no good way to block the
check
okay that worked out nicely because my
time is low
wait a minute rook takes it's better to
start with bishop c4 and then rook a5
thanks for subbing i'm a kanesh
or maybe i'm a niche
and noah bear oh you come from levy i
come from levy
oh what does that even mean
you maybe you're lovies
are you a creation of lovey
or maybe levy had a bunch of children
and now they're
they're spreading well welcome yeah if
you're new here
this is chess playing a one-hour long
bullet tournament i'm in second place
wow
halloween halloween has more than double
my points
um it's still very early
just gonna try and be solid i'll play a
ponziani
it's a favorite opening of mine knight
g4 is not a great move
had this position recently take the
knight and then bishop b5
um
how do the pieces move again
why am i freezing here i just don't know
what to do and it's an interesting
position
i'll play this move threatening mate
this might just lead to trades
oh okay let's take twice and then damage
the structure the queen can swing over
or not now attacking c6
queen still defends g2 check
okay threatening maiden one still
defending g2
have to move back i want to play this
move in fork
let's just trade queens
okay that's a fork
let's trade rooks
eric what's your favorite song um
alexa what's my favorite song alexa
knows better
oh alexa what's my favorite song
according to an alexa answers
contributor happy birthday to you
oh
what oh look so louder
so happy birthday to you
i wonder how i knew that
birthday is in oh my birthday is next
week already
and time is fine oh i'm playing richie
rich again
i was preparing for richie rich earlier
it's gonna be a london
oh let's take that oh c3
unexpected i'll play bishop f5 and then
f6
this is a cool line idea g5 h5
here i play e6
and going for the storm i want the
knight here
because this line is strong
i really don't know what to make of this
position
it looks playable
oh
it's interesting
have to be very careful here
i think the king is very safe this is a
nice umbrella of ponds
hey fun fact my birthday is on the
second oh
neighbors birth neighbors i'm one day
after that
happy early birthday
thanks for the early birthday gift
okay so i'm up on time that's what
matters most
this is still okay
very confusing position
that was a good move
man i'm getting crushed here no i'm
getting mated oh
richie rich richie rich is a strong
player
underrated okay let's recover that was
the first loss
hopefully the last loss play a two
knights attack
and play b3
oh that's not a good move opponent was
well prepared
okay so threatening this and also this
okay this is now a double attack
i want to play this move or this move
or this move
where's my win
there's my win okay winning the queen oh
okay that's still fine was not expecting
queen e4
uh let's do this
just oh no no no no i want to take to
take the queen
not rookie three my time too
the good thing is black's king is on d4
and the queen was still hanging
okay should still be an easy win
there we go okay just enough time there
all right so the goal the goal is to win
the tournament
top ten oh fool dan full down playing i
need revenge on full damn oh
i'm playing full dan time for revenge
what does cooldown play most recent
youtube video was a game against full
dan
it was a stafford oh this is a latvian
um i ever studied the latvian
let's take that let's take that
i don't think knight g4 is like a main a
main line
um but it's still interesting let's play
e5
i just want to play normal moves
and use my pawns to control space
as well as my bishop
okay this is sweet sweet revenge
e6 this pawn's pinned
oh the queen's hanging oh okay
11 move revenge victory good game pull
down
i still have nightmares about full dance
under promotion tonight
checkmating my my king along with my
hopes and dreams
let's suppose let's play e5 and maybe
stafford gambit
[Music]
maybe four nights oh center for trick
it's a fun line queen goes back the
bishop develops
very pleasant position
let's uh let's go for a fishing pole
or just meat
hope and dream bits yeah
don't want them to be crushed
check i think i'll castle next
i don't mind if the h file opens i
always play f6
94 now i'll counter attack
my bishop is still attacked but white
doesn't really want to take it
i don't really want to move it oh it
takes it
g5 incoming i'm trapping the bishop
mead is very close where's the mate hmm
let me see the mate to take
it's so close
yay my subadversary
soup anniversary yeah
you know what i pre-moved this if white
got one more move king e4 it would have
been stalemate
that would have been a really funny
really tragic stalemate if this happened
like stalemating the king in the center
with two queens
i was so lucky my opponent flag there
because king e4 was the only legal move
too
like i dream of this okay
back to tournaments i was very lucky to
win that
so still alive
malcolm reynolds thanks for subbing
johnny pache oh let's wizard i just want
one stafford
it's not this game another center fork
trick just had the same opening
thanks for being one of my two favorite
eriksen chess can you guess the other
one
oh uh probably hansen
or maybe there's a grandmaster eric
lebron
related to lebron james
a free queen okay maybe free mates maybe
not yet
are there any other eric's
maybe mattered monkey
more bits for correcting
yes he's he's a roommate of mine
but he's been a very absent roommate
thank you the iceberger
i'm trying to anagram the iceberger into
something with eric
it's an anagram of the eric burge
also scotty too or scotty v2 thanks for
subbing berserk again
okay london time maybe or maybe not
okay london versus slav
so okay i like the h file
i'll just try and play naturally
this is a very typical idea
already very difficult for black
pawns are smiling big time it's castle
queen side
always play king b1
black's actually surviving here
let's take that okay maybe black's not
surviving here
but i have 12 seconds
okay let's go for the mating attack
[Music]
my pawns are so strong
oh it's not meat yet here's meat
okay hey second place
tied for first but maybe slightly worse
five breaks
let's go
oh eric nakamura
let's go eric because naca naca adopted
me maybe
oh and jack jack 1574. thanks for
subbing
let's do another london last game worked
out well
f6 is slightly weird
it's close to mate oh it's not me yet
though
it's having a hallucination
i there to open the center
we have a rook to the file
let's be careful yeah the bishop's
actually trapped because the pawns
pinned
thanks for subbing war
war master 2000 appreciate that
okay maid is is coming
okay
oh it's war master i was thinking warm
master but thanks that's a new sub
okay let's go search again let's play
another
another staffing gambit this time a real
stafford gambit
okay
we have we have like the main this is a
trap that everyone falls for
g3 queen takes g3 and then i'm mating
um this is also winning this is force
mate now
white has no way to stop mate there's
this move then this move and then just
meet
or this and then this and mate
this is why i play the stafford like
it's so easy for white to fall into
these things
yeah okay had to crush the the bone
crusher
hey first place let's go yeah that was
the first real stafford of the
the tournament
it's a great opening for bullets because
it's hard to
hard to refute without spending some
time
let's play this sign
so i want a pawn i'm down on time
so f6 uh discouraging g5
oh my i'm in some trouble
counter-attack i have to watch out for
g5
okay that worked out well
to watch out for this rook h1 move which
i'm allowing
yeah but both kings are a bit awkward
okay this one's a rook
my time to move a little bit quicker
we're gonna have two wins the queen
i might just make another queen or
opponent resigns okay that was nice
have you seen agad matar in a while
i see a good mantra almost every day
youtube is always
recommending his videos
maybe someday we'll do another another
four-player chess
collaboration okay going for the sign
hey it's lucky 900 tv thanks for gifting
a sub
to j for yc something something
appreciate that the first sub gift to
the channel
okay so here we have something that
resembles a sicilian
just going for simple development
oh my bishop please don't see it please
opponent saw it
i was gonna play knight g3 but then
queen takes g3 because my f pawns pinned
i feel like time is going to be a
problem for for my opponent this game
even though box playing quite well for
helping me sleep at night
oh you're welcome oblivious maximus
i'm glad i can play a role in your
ability to sleep i'm down i'm down a
bishop and a knight but i can take the
rook
at some point when the time is right
actually i'm just winning the rook
there's no bishop e6
black's also flagging
another rook's entering the game
[Music]
okay whoa lucky gifting five more subs
thanks so much lucky 900 tv
gifting to dink dangler loophold
underscore
in new minion a and brew ways
and chazza presents thanks so much
appreciate that let's not berserk this
game
upon slightly higher rated opponents
also in
second place we have a mainline
catalan playing the ray robson variation
i did not qualify for the that qualifier
event
another day that was my previous stream
i played the first qualifier
it started well ended pretty badly and
then i was tired
um and i i didn't end up playing the the
next qualifiers
and going for the pawn storm
it's a slightly annoying move bishop's
going to be kicked
around though but here here
here that's also possible
so removing the queen from defending the
bishop
also controlling f4
let's take
so it's all about holding on to this
pawn which
might be very difficult to do but i'll
try
encounter attacking the knight and
defending the pawn
so if it takes takes there's this or
this
the queen will chill expecting this
probably want to go for this
oh no my pawn please take it
opponent two wise let's push the pawn
that's a good move
but okay i'm going to win this pawn oh
but lose this pawn
but then mate
okay time scramble time or just free
pawn time
[Music]
hey it's another sub i think it's not oh
my queen
the curse of another sub
no i flagged
oh thanks another son
regretful regretful something i'm so
regretful about this game
i just hung a queen what was this move
oh queen d3 so sneaky i saw the check
so i was just focused on this quadrant
of the board and forgot my queen existed
oh i deserve that kind of i'm still
very far ahead in the lead
and there's a 15 point cushion
we're only halfway through the
tournament not even halfway
wow this is a very low rated iron
lucky tv gifting another sub
okay have one of these lines
oh this is like um what you call it
folk beer counter gambit
i don't mind this position
try and exploit the queen the queen is
tied down to the bishop
it's going to be sharp some point i want
to play this and win the pawn
let's go for another fishing pole it
worked well that previous game
so i'm down a piece but this knight is
uh looking very juicy
unfortunately queen b2 is coming
so let's just bring in another piece
maybe this move coming
um
trying to calculate
just try this this better work
i see three ideas
it's getting complex
it's getting very complex
i'm losing a lot of material
but maybe winning a lot of material
there we go i want my bishops hanging
but the rook's attacked okay so i'm
still
i have this move check bishop e2 and
then i'll take
so i'm still down in bishop and down a
little bit of time
but there's still comp
turning this maybe this idea
[Music]
hope to one day get a high enough
ranking that we play someday
someday yeah thanks for that regretful
something something
okay this is all about time now
rook d2 preventing bishop d5
just got a slow light down
okay
what is this oh it's jay
how's it going jay if knight c3 did my
opponent have mates oh
maybe that was a very confusing game
[Music]
oh hey it's e-man visiting the world
chess hall of fame
i walk i i do walk by there sometimes
but is uh is a museum open i know the
chess club has been open
queen d5 tricky
this pawn is it's delicate
the the plus in this position is i have
the bishop hair
and a nice open d file
yeah there's going to be pressure
against black's pawn
just blockade it this is very pleasant
so 98 i can take take and then bishop e7
wins material
this also wins material
threatening this
thanks for playing the stafford gambit
so much lately my pleasure i had a lot
of fun playing it a bunch today
um nice it's still a fun opening to play
like there's still there's still a very
large portion
of the population that doesn't know what
to do against it
and just falls for traps
okay so we have a actually have a pretty
close position
oh we can move
king wants to be here
delayed bon cloud
here we go winning the rook
okay
oh there's another international master
in second
trying to catch up maybe join slightly
after me
oh is there anything to do with the
chess club um
i'm actually not sure i haven't been
inside the chess club
in months it's best to call because i
think you might have to schedule
time in advance or you just have to
like on the web their website
so the same with chess club is
organizing
like a super online event
in in maybe a couple weeks
featuring kasparov magnus and hikaru
like just the biggest names in chess so
it should be fun
unfortunately it's not in person
probably would have been in person if
there wasn't uh this pandemic
but it should be very fun to watch
almost as fun as this position
this e file e file's so nice
i just want to complete the alignment
yeah look at this e-file and bring the
king to e2
yeah it's so pleasant oh my time
spent too much time admiring the e-file
do
three seconds
yes opponent meant to take my final pawn
oh i feel bad about that it was really
spicy
really spicy almost as spicy as
this crushed pepper i don't know why
it's sitting on the desk but
a spicy dirty flag okay um
we move on and
let's not berserk let's play
against a london oh dork dork 96 night
thanks for subbing with prime
and
oh thanks for the spicy bits spicy bits
yeah okay so we have some
like typical london position
idea this this an attack the pawn
all this is very very typical
i i like the structure with both sides
so now i want to access the b file
oh i hope you can sleep
whoever is suffering from insomnia
threatening this because upon oh
forgot about that i should probably stay
focused
take first and then this
this is interesting bishop can be strong
maybe
um
i feel like i'm getting outplayed
but maybe not
still up on time
oh that was a really bad move
opponent flags though another another
dirty flag
man oh thank you but bugs
the bugs is uh something at tier one
another new sub oh lysamir having
insomnia maybe
and asap welcome back hope you're doing
well
okay so moving quickly is paying off
i'll play e4 this game
i'll have a two nights attack versus
carol khan
better clean off that flag yeah
need some strong disinfectant
i don't entirely know what i'm doing
here
looks interesting though
just start pushing pawns thanks for
subbing e-man
9871 thanks so much
yeah just going for oh so i'm going for
the
the eventual g5
but i'm i'm going to be patient just try
and build up
put the bishop here there's really no
rush
you just want to make sure all the
pieces are optimized oh that's a good
move
we're trading pawns opponent wanted to
play that
it's still pleasant
f5 cuts off the bishop
it's a very sad bishop i'm winning this
pawn
check attacking this and this
what to play it's a pleasant position
i'm just not sure what to play
maybe this move defending
i could take and then this
it's interesting
threading made in two okay
worked out nicely
a slightly weird game kind of slow
played that one
so 21 minutes left oh gm adley strong
player
from egypt uh berserk again
trying to keep the distance between the
rest of the crowd
i'm gonna be greedy trying to defend the
pawn going for b4
oh i'm allowing i was allowing knight
takes e4 there
the greeniness is paying off
hinging this
okay this is winning material
oh that's losing material
okay not the greatest position
or time situation without losing another
pawn
but trying to fight
box position is a little bit delicate
and by a little bit i mean a lot yeah
this is this is completely winning now
king of fade is probably the best move i
can take
go after this pawn
okay that's a nice game i was in trouble
there's some fluctuations in terms of
like who was up and down material
um jay i see your question ask me that
after
after this tournament just feel free to
copy paste it save it for later
gotta play a walrus wall restrict
declined
okay so double berserking i lost a pawn
still a decent position
okay there we go so we both kind of
blundered
after this wow so i won both rooks
now winning the bishop because the
knight's pinned okay
what was the question oh how do i change
my play from aggressive
and unsound into positional and karpov
like oh
study the games of karpov
that's what my coach had me do when i
was i was around 1600
i studied a lot of car park games and
you'll get a sense
you'll get a sense for his style
oh hi live love welcome back how's it
going
so double berserking stonewall
and try and be solid
my goal is to castle queenside
yeah continue being solid actually the
king might just be happy
on f2
completely shutting down the queen side
that's a good move and lock's going to
take over the a-file or not
plunder the pawn there black didn't take
it
let's check
okay
yeah these these double berserking games
i have to kind of work to stay focused
a very nice lead between the rest of the
the competition
okay having whatever this is oh no my
bishop
but actually my bishop um
let's take that this is interesting
there's some comp
i have the h file i have the light
squares
my center oh but i'm losing another pawn
play this move taken g5
okay how bad is this
this pawn has been hanging forever
um i don't know if i can take it now i
played this move
alexa how do i get rid of a dead body
good try good try
it's going to take a lot of work to not
lose this
is the queen trapped the queen's almost
trapped
line oh good move
another good move
[Music]
okay
just gotta start pre-moving everything
ah okay that was rough
i got i got my bishop trapped very early
in that game
appointment played a weird opening okay
let's reserve let's try and come back
and maybe finish the tournament
on the good notes oh opponent opponent
almost not here
okay stafford gambit no stafford gambit
center fork trick
um let's take
this is a tricky line
this is kind of like a reverse stafford
like white's the one who sacked a pawn
i'm pretty sure f6 is the best move
uh play six
and being super safe i just want to do
this this this
and not get mated or wow that's a good
move or is it
it's okay for me
and this is okay
everything's still very safe
[Music]
i still have castling rights too
not sure if i want to use them
oh i'm pinned good move
why people happy you might not know what
that means but why are people happy
what does that mean oh that's not
stalemate good okay king had legal moves
wide people whose people and why is it
wide and happy
thank you xx alter xx solving for five
months
all right that's berserk again
you should probably bust out the bomb
oh maybe but we're gonna try and
[Music]
be civil
oh chat chad is confused maybe more
confused than me
chat doing things with why people happy
but why
i'm so confused
chad is more interesting than this game
right now
thank you smash b let's take this thing
i think i'm winning a bishop
queen and bishop are hanging there's no
yeah there's no way for the queen to
defend the bishop
queen c1 i play rook d1
i'm just trying to confuse my opponent
oh i could have taken here
should have taken there
here we go
okay i'm still uh
still a 30 point lead i think i'm safe
uh oh playing playing the i am in
third place let's play london
okay we have one of these yet again
okay let's invent something just trying
to play ultra aggressively
it's kind of paying off this pawn's
hanging
oh this pawn if knight takes i have this
move
so it's still interesting
a lot of confusion here pretty sure that
was a mouse slip
i still have to be careful
idea 92 in castle thanks for subbing
i'm holding something rope
regardless of eric's enthusiasm never go
full london
oh i don't know how
enthusiastic i am about that advice
turning something like this
look at this oh because the rook and the
pawn are pinned
so i'm winning yeah i was winning the
queen at least after bishop takes
i was like a nice double pin
okay that was very nice
oh berenson chess offering
slightly dubious opening advice
speaking of dubious opening let's play a
stafford
ah i can't play a stafford here can i do
i could jerome let's jerome
jerome time bam jerome
so i'm still down at peace but
the king is on f2
um my my theory is a little bit rusty
here
play h5
attack the queen attack the knight
okay jerome is kind of working
which is not a sentence you usually hear
leave the the pins
i'm still down on time oh that's a good
move
it's actually a really good move i don't
want to trade queens
unfortunately i'm not winning the rook
now well i'll still get some
some pawn movements
going for this move that's a great move
i have to play a6
and trouble
i don't want to let jerome down
oh my rook
opponent didn't take it
what is this game
wow jerome too strong
don't mess with the jerome jerome
thanks you for your service my pleasure
my pleasure
okay that wasn't a totally real jerome
but it was something
okay so let's try and get a hundred
hundred turning points
have this opening again
i think this is a move actually let's
play this move
i'll just be solid visited the stl chess
oh really
wait same person it's really cool to see
where so many lectures take place
no way wait does that mean two people in
the chat having visited
a st louis chess club today
you guys should should coordinate and
play each other maybe
or it might just be the same person i'm
not sure
that's cool
that's like the probably the the best
place for chess in the us
oh i might miss the rook okay maybe i'm
mating
this is looking nice giving away a
knight
hoping to have something in return
probably bishop c4 coming
oh four people so far oh
but maybe that's a joke i don't know
let's take that thing
my f-pawn this kind of backfired
what to do here it's really backfired
of this move
yeah we'll trade everything that's a
good move
or is it
time scramble time
okay that's close it's kind of close
99 okay need one more one more
tournament points
to get to 100. keep up the great work
thumbs up
oh thanks for that julian g
playing another another i am i played
this person earlier
i think next e3 was played
i have no idea what this is looks cool
though
it's probably slightly dubious
so the goal is to do this and win this
good move wanna do this move
and 120 points yeah
oh for lysamir thanks lightsamer
reminding me what i need to do
with 500 bits thanks so much
okay so we just traded as one big
fancy trade now it's equal material
white has center pawns
now i have one center pawn white also
has two bishops
it looks solid though
it's opposite color bishops
i like this construction it's hard for
light to break
i might just want a sack actually just
sack
and then use uh use the h-pawn
[Music]
this is risky
so again it's equal material
i have a lot of time to work with
okay
broke a hundred let's go 103. that's
berserk again
this could be the last game
so i'll try and play uber aggressively
ever and i can't i know i can't stop
playing it either
i'm even trying to play it against
whatever this is
whoa it's lucky tv gifting gifting more
subs
thanks so much
uh let's have some fun and just for
lucky tv
oh free queen because the pond's pinned
ooh whoa it's gm hikaru
wait gifting a sub gifting a sub to gm
hikaru
things lucky tv
gifting gifting to row row row roberts
gm hikaru vulgar samurai
red x yeti and v con15
really appreciate that oh playing okay
this is a final game
oh playing a higher rated player let's
focus
and try and finish strong
okay one of these lines
this is an interesting line going for
the attack
let's go okay making it sharp
a solid position locks a bit
underdeveloped probably want to go for
this attack
queen g6 entering black's crib
pawn is pinned
i'm looking for the ventral mate
i think there's this
oh there's this move yeah this is
completely
winning the black doesn't have any
checks in time
the only check is this or this okay that
was a nice game
a nice little london breakthrough
okay whoa
leech has changed these are new right
they changed their little
trophy things they look more colorful
a little bit more cartoonish
and it's so satisfying
i think so much off the schniede and
with the hundred bits
subbing and corp tech and dan the finest
and lysomere and malcolm reynolds
that might take some additional work
yeah this might have to go on youtube
like full unedited
uncut also compact buffalo thanks so
much
and ninja ninja with arisa thanks ninja
shout out to ninja who's um an
up and coming twitch streamer recently
started
streaming on twitch like not too long
ago